we're now at the end of the first week
of September 2015 so it's time for me to
do another monthly update video in which
I'll talk about what we did during
August and what we've got coming up
during September before I go into those
sections in a bit more detail I'd like
to very quickly highlight three big
things that I'm particularly interested
in and I think you will be as well the
first of these is that September 12
starts my next class with a global
Center for Advanced Studies a
philosophical foundations class a
12-week fully online class you can take
it from anywhere in the world that
you've got access and it's going to meet
on Saturdays by video conferencing from
two to four eastern standard time tell
you more about that in the September
section the September the second thing
that I want to talk about is the half
hour hagel series we've reached a really
critical juncture we're now in the
middle of the self-consciousness section
which if you know your Hagel you know
that's where the most popular discussion
topic of hegel for the twenty twentieth
and twenty-first century the
master-slave dialectic that's where that
that part occurs so we will in fact be
talking about the master-slave dialectic
by the end of September we're getting
ready for that we're in the preparatory
stuff in the beginning parts of
self-consciousness the third thing is
i'm going to start shooting a new kind
of video one that is focused on current
events i'm going to be doing this about
once or twice a month probably just once
this month and i'm going to look at
things that are very very much in the
public eye very timely controversial and
bring a philosopher's perspective to
those i'll be drawing out a lot of other
philosophers not just myself but
philosophical perspectives to that so
watch for that video coming up later
this month and now let's talk about
what's going on in August
August was a very busy month it's really
becoming a refrain that that each month
is busy because there's there's so many
things going on but it really was quite
quite a busy month we had four events
some of them were online and some of
them were as we say on-site or
face-to-face one of them was the eighth
lecture in the understanding anger
series which has been hosted by the
Kingston Public Library we had a great
discussion about the early Christian
theologians and philosophers and their
positions on anger of course we couldn't
cover everybody because there's an awful
lot of thinkers but we did manage to
touch on five of them tertullian
lactantius John Demasi John Chrysostom
and Augustine so that was a really great
discussion and you can see the link to
it in the video description we also had
I got invited in to give another guest
sermon at the unitarian universalist
community the catskills and i used
rainer maria rilke as conception of
solitude a little bit updated for the
Internet age to talk about solitude
slowing down and clearing space very
well received I didn't get video of it
but i did get audio recording and i also
have the sermon transcript if you're
interested in that so that'll be linked
below as well I did the first public
half hour hagel Q&A session through a
google hangout I actually did it from a
rest stop coming back up from from the
city to where we live currently in the
Hudson Valley and that's when I say
public what I mean is my patreon
subscribers one of the benefits that
they have as supporters of the the hagel
project is that I've been having monthly
QA hangouts for them where they could
ask me anything that they liked about
about Hagel but now once we reached a
certain level of support for the videos
which for which I'm very thankful I said
as a public service i'm going to start
offering just anybody can come in and
ask me questions about Hagel once a
month so we did the first of those great
Congress
patients covering Hegel's phenomenology
getting a little bit into Heidegger a
little bit into some other people as
well and then I guess it's really been
quite a Hagel event a month because the
other thing that we had was the global
Center for Advanced Studies summer
phenomena summer of the Hagel
phenomenology reading group I forget
exactly how they phrased it but they
have a very clever way of putting it in
any case they were doing a online
reading group going through Hegel's
phenomenology they asked me to give
another guest lecture so I came in and
talked about the religion section but
only the first two portions of it not
the third part which is revealed
religion we talked about nature religion
and religion and works of art and very
interesting stuff so that was events
video production we got quite a bit done
during the month of August if you've
been following the channel you've seen
these getting released several half-hour
Hagel videos we finished up with force
in the understanding which meant we
finished with the consciousness section
and we launched into the
self-consciousness section I released
one and three so for videos total of
those this last month over in my
critical thinking and logic and
argumentation channel we did some more
fallacy videos I still have some more to
do with those but but we got a few of
those out but where I was really
concentrating on was core concept videos
dealing with Plato's symposium because I
was teaching that global Center for
Advanced Studies class so that is
probably a good segue into talking about
the symposium class that just finished
up about a week ago we did a four-week
entirely online five session course in
the global Center for Advanced Studies
at sort of the end of the summer session
kickoff of the new fall session and i
decided i was going to teach on plato's
symposium which is a text that i really
enjoy we had nine students sign up and
we had a lot of really great discussions
i provide
did them with a ton of handouts and
lessons and links and I I also decided
to shoot a series of 20 core concept
videos for them many of which I've
released some of which I still have to
release so great experience all around
what else went on during august i was
working on some academic writing
continuing to polish up the ants on
paper that i gave well at the very end
of july in in boston continuing work on
my my Marcel projects getting one paper
ready for the the Marcel society meeting
coming up in October polishing up the
other paper on Marcel and Christian
philosophy and then I've been working on
a paper on 18 Jill songs conception of
Christian philosophy and Suren
Kierkegaard's philosophical fragments
and how they fit together again for
another conference session that's coming
up in October so I also did some some
consulting work here and there beneful
Asafa counseling I've been working on
the blogs trying to tidy them up a bit
you know tighten up the structure add a
lot more resources in there and I did
manage to get some blogging done during
August which was one of my main goals I
did a little bit of writing in her exes
do you know NTK my main blog the one
that I started five years ago back at
Fayetteville State University I wrote a
bit for heavy metal philosopher which is
my complete side project my indulgence
blog and then I wrote quite a bit of the
half-hour hagel blog you know trying to
you know publicize what was going on
there's been a lot of cool developments
the other thing I should mention too
that happened in August with respect to
the half-hour hagel series that I didn't
write down on this this sort of
spreadsheet of all things going on was
open culture featured the half-hour
hagel series in in their their website
which is really great because it gets us
some more attention it brings in people
who might benefit from reading the you
know the
the text and doing so along with the
videos so great thing all around that
was the month of August
what's coming up in September we don't
have quite as many events and actually
one of the events is past if I'd been
doing this video on the first like I
intended to I'd be talking about it as a
future event now I'm going to tell you
about it as a past event I went on to
theology matters which is an internet
radio show on the third which was
Thursday and talked a bit about my my
2011 book which i happen to have sitting
here reason fulfilled by revelation the
1930s Christian philosophy debates in
France quite a mouthful fortunately it
does fit on the book cover quite easily
and so I talked a bit about the debates
and about you know you know what the
issues were and the notion of Christian
philosophy it's a call-in show so we did
have a one call in who wanted to ask me
about some of the topics that I was
talking about and about Gary gula garage
and and so we got off on to quite a few
tangents but it was a good show
September 12 at ten-thirty if you're up
here in the kingston area we have the
final lecture and the understanding
anger Series the ninth lecture and this
one is focused directly on Thomas
Aquinas and his views on anger how he's
synthesizing many of the people that
we've covered so far these ancient
Christian authors all these philosophers
and bringing them together in one you
know sort of synthetic perspective on
the emotion of anger he actually has
quite a bit of useful stuff to tell us
about it so again September 12 1030am at
the kingston public library if you
happen to be in the area September 23rd
whether you're you're in the area or not
we have an online half hour hagel Q&A
session at six pm eastern standard time
that will be through a google hangout
i'll post the link on my facebook and on
my Google+ page probably put it in
Twitter as well that is public that's
available to anybody whether they are
supporters of the half-hour hagel
project or not so if you have any
questions about about Hagel
thought his works as influence you know
even you say well who is this Hagel guy
you can come in and I'll answer your
questions I may answer them at quite a
bit of life which tends to be the case
with dealing with angle things but I can
promise you I'll certainly try to
address them that's all we've got for as
far as events going on in September but
that's already quite a bit given the
other things that are happening in
September video production here's what I
what I intend to get done I want to get
six videos for the half hour Hagel
series done I've already released two of
them so far for this month I'm going to
be shooting a lot of footage this month
for half hour Hagel's as we get ready
for the move which I'll talk about a bit
more in a minute but what they have our
Hagel series what's really cool about
this is we are now on the cusp of moving
into the famous master-slave dialectic
which is probably the portion of Hegel
that most people tend to focus on or at
least have in the last century so we
will be knee-deep in that by the end of
the month I'm going to release some more
critical thinking videos still focused
on the fallacies those of you who've
been writing you know comments on them
thanks for doing that I'm always happy
to see what you make of them I've got a
number of Plato's symposium videos that
I originally shot for that that
symposium class that finished up august
31st or something those i'm going to be
continually releasing probably two or
three a week because i want to get those
out into general circulation as soon as
possible so i can start shooting some
other core concept videos as well and
like i said i'm going to try something
new this month which is shooting one
current event video so i'm going to pick
one current event i think it might be a
little bit late for for trying to talk
about the Ashley Madison data release
thing and all the things that that says
about desire
and you know two wrongs making it right
and all the interesting things along
those lines but i'm pretty sure that
something else will happen this month
that is newsworthy and could be
illuminated by philosophy so I'll you
know be thinking about that and keeping
an eye out for that if you see something
that you think particularly catches your
eye send it my way and i will i will
consider shooting a video on that i'm
back to to a lot of teaching all of my
teaching is online but online teaching
requires quite a bit you get to to do it
from home but you also have to build all
the content and do all the grading as
you normally would for MERIS classes I
don't have to meet with students in in
sessions although I do answer a lot of
messages back and forth and follow their
forums but for the global Center for
Advanced Studies every single week we
have a two hour video conference session
where I prepared slides and I lead
students in discussion of the issues or
texts or topics that were recovering
that's you know essentially like a class
you know seminar so I've got two merest
world views and values classes that open
up tomorrow they begin tomorrow
officially I've got all of that material
built loaded there were a few glitches
because they updated their Sakai
interface which meant that a few things
dropped out here and there had to be put
back in but I thank God willing
everything is online and ready to be
taken care of I may develop a few more
handouts for them you know every
semester I try to add some more
resources for the students to put a bit
more value into the classes the global
Center for Advanced Studies like I said
before the class that I'm teaching with
them this fall semester is a 12-week
three-credit entirely online
philosophical foundations class if
you're interested in this class I'll put
some information you know about about
you know I'll put some links to more
information below it is a class in which
we are going to be reading a lot of
selections by classic and contemporary
philosophers
grappling with some of the major issues
in some of the major fields of
philosophy so we're actually going to
look at you know let's say for example
metaphysics we'll talk about the you
know issue of freedom versus determinism
or in ethics we'll talk about you know
what is what is the nature of the good
or you know Reich's versus duties or
things like that and and for each
subject area like that I will have three
reading selections all of which by the
way are available as PDFs free to
students so you don't to buy a textbook
and we'll look at each one of them sort
of compare and contrast that's what we
do in our class sessions and that's a
great way I think for students to get
introduced to the discipline you read
some day Kurt you read some play-doh you
read some Spinoza you read some Hume you
know read a whole bunch of people and
get to talk with somebody who you can
tell is very passionate and interested
in philosophy and get to you know meet
fellow students online and interact with
them great way to to get your feet wet
in philosophy or if you want a refresher
course to do well with that you can take
it for credit or you can also audit the
class which means then you don't have to
do the homework and you know to take the
test but you you know you also don't get
credit for it but it's a lot of fun so
that's what I've got as far as teaching
going on academic writing I've already
mentioned the projects that I was
working on during August none of which
have been brought to fruition yet they
all you know academic writing takes
quite a while it is to sort of peel back
the veil a bit I'm still working out all
those papers and and I'm also working on
something else I need to get a
prospectus ready I had a publisher who
was interested in my writing a book on
anger for them and I said yeah that
sounds great I committed to do that so i
need to actually provide them with a
prospectus pretty soon that says here's
what chapter one is going to be about
here's chapter two here's you know when
you write these sort of things i don't
want to go into too great detail but
there's there's a lot of stuff that goes
interview say who else is doing some
more work and will this cell and why
will it
so I got to do a bit of taking
everything that I've got up here and
putting it down on paper for that I'm
going to be doing a lot more blogging
over the course of this month I've
already written a bit in the half-hour
Hagel and in her exes t know NTK my goal
is actually to write something in every
one of my five blogs this month so
that's our exes Dino I take a half hour
Hagel heavy metal philosopher and then
the two that have been just sitting
there not really doing much for quite a
while samplers existentialism updates
focused on existentialism virtue ethics
digest focused particularly on virtue
ethics but also an ethics more broadly
so I need to I need to start you know
doing a bit more disciplined work with
those and the other big thing of course
the you might say the elephant in the
room is that we are getting ready for a
move from here in the Hudson Valley to
milwaukee wisconsin which is where we
are relocating to both my wife and i are
originally from the area we're really
looking forward to getting back there
and getting to spend a lot more time
with their families with old friends you
know we love the the New York Hudson
Valley area it's been been great to be
here it's been great to go down to the
city and all the other cities around but
there you know there's also no place
like home as well so everything that I'm
doing here I'm going to be doing there
as well the philosophical counseling
speaking the YouTube production like
you're seeing right here the writing
teaching classes although that's going
to stay the same but I'm going to be in
a different area or we're going to be in
a different area and a lot of cool stuff
going on right now what that means is a
lot of packing a lot of boxes and a lot
of you know moving things from from
place to place and getting them ready in
sort of a staging area so that's you
know that takes surprisingly more time
than you would think that it does but
that's what's going on the Leigh
thing that I'll say is if you're looking
for somebody for for public talk if you
think you might benefit from tutoring or
philosophical counseling you want to get
in touch with me the best way to do so
is Greg at reason I owe you can also
visit our reason I o dot com website
where you'll find all the different sort
of services that we offer through reason
IL it's a company whose motto is
philosophy into practice that's what I
do that's what my focus on this entire
project with the the YouTube channel is
part of that so if you're interested in
that sort of thing get in contact with
me otherwise have a great month enjoy
the videos and if you can make it to any
of these events show up and we'll have a
great time